in the United States the Supreme Court
is set to hear a landmark case that
could upend Donald Trump's bid to return
to the White House today the country's
highest court will hear arguments on
Colorado's decision to kick Trump off
the upcoming primary ballot over his
efforts to overturn the results of the
2020 election our Washington bureau
chief Jackson prasu is outside the
Supreme Court right now Jackson we
appreciate this so historic case
obviously uh what exactly are the
justices being asked to
side good morning to you Anthony perhaps
the biggest election related case that
the Supreme Court has taken up since
bush bush Vore back in 2000 the court
has to decide a number of things the
name the main question here is whether
Trump is eligible to be remaining on the
ballot in the election or if he can be
kicked off as Colorado Supreme Court has
said he can be uh you know the real
question here is did Donald Trump engage
in an Insurrection because the Colorado
Su Supreme Court ruled that he did that
he should be removed from the ballot for
violating article 14 Section 3 of the US
Constitution which essentially
disqualifies anyone who engaged in an
Insurrection from holding public office
from appearing on the ballot so that's
question one the Supreme Court has to
decide did Trump violate that section of
the Constitution uh not question two
they have to figure out is did Trump
engage in an Insurrection and part of
the argument being made by Trump's legal
team is that look Trump has never been
convicted of engaging in an Insurrection
yes there's a criminal trial underway
right now but uh he was never convicted
by the Senate during the impeachment
proceedings he hasn't been convicted in
a court of law at this point and so
these are sort of the issues the court
has to to weigh in on here in deciding
whether or not to uphold what Colorado
Supreme Court has already decided which
is that Trump cannot appear on the
primary ballot in that state uh on super
Tuesday which is March 5th okay so
unprecedented what would a win for
either side mean
obviously well for Trump a win of course
would be Vindication essentially saying
look it's up to to voters to decide who
becomes the president not up to
legislators also that Trump's legal
arguments here hold water that he did
not engage in an Insurrection but I sat
down yesterday with the Colorado lawyer
who fought and won the original case in
that state and who will be arguing it
here today and he says look if their
side is upheld it will disqualify trump
it will end his presidential bid because
they believe that this will essentially
give a green light to states that have
laws on the books that say that
candidates Who are ineligible under the
Constitution can't appear on the ballot
and in those states that don't have laws
like that by the time the election is
over in November and the electoral
college has to certify some states will
be legally barred from certifying a
disqualified presidential candidate
which would be Donald Trump if this
ruling is upheld obviously there's a lot
of concerns from both sides that if the
Supreme Court is ultimately somewhat
ambiguous in its decision here that that
could spell a really uh messy series of
legal fights right across the country so
it'll be really interesting today to
watch the arguments and see which way
the just IES are heading and how much of
this case which specific aspects of this
case they feel that they need to take up
by the way Anthony the clock is ticking
here because as I mentioned super
Tuesday is March 5th in Colorado they're
hearing the arguments today they likely
need a decision here in just the next
couple of weeks so that there's some
clarity in Colorado and the other states
coming down the line well I'm glad you
brought that up because the urgency
obviously is there normally cases can
take months uh for a decision so
obviously it timeline is is of course
important uh but I understand this isn't
the only Trump related case headed to
the Supreme Court what else is going
on that's right on Tuesday of this week
we of course got that DC appeals court
ruling about Trump's claim that he is
immune from prosecution in the election
interference case brought by special
counsel Jack Smith and of course the DC
Court says that Trump does not enjoy
presidential immunity but they gave a
Monday deadline this coming Monday for
Trump's team to file an appeal to the
Supreme Court to see if the Supreme
Court Court will take up the case Trump
has already said that he will be filing
that appeal now it's not clear if and
when they will submit the paperwork and
then it becomes a question of whether or
not the Supreme Court does in fact
decide to hear that case now in this
case odds are sort of 5050 that they may
stand by the Lower Court ruling and say
there's nothing for us to look at here
but they may also decide to take it up
so that is another major case that could
be before The Supreme Court a question
of how much power a president has and
that one is interesting one Anthony
because essentially Trump's argument is
that he is beyond the reach of the
Supreme Court you have to wonder how the
justices including the ones that Trump
appointed there are three of them will
feel about a case like that that's
fascinating the political drama heading
to the courtroom today we appreciate
this Jackson thank you for that update
that is uh our Washington bureau chief
Jack sasco joining us from the US
capital thank you again